car en pologne ces ukrainiens n'ont
qu'une idée prendre le premier train
pour rentrer dans leur pays faire le
chemin inverse pour résister comme cette
infirmière qui avait pourtant réussi à
fuir
je vais revenir
je suis soignante sur les hôpitaux ont
besoin de bras et je resterai jusqu'à la
fin
cet homme expatrié aux états unis vient
un drone dans ses bagages pour défendre
son pays natal l'ukraine je veux que mes
enfants et mes petits enfants viennent
dans une ukraine libre je suis convaincu
qu elles le sont avec je pourrais bien à
visiter ma ville vivent à mes quatre
petits-enfants
comme depuis le début de l'invasion
186 milles personnes sont rentrées en
ukraine pour défendre leur pays certains
prennent les armes d'autres en fabrique
remplissant ses caisses de cocktails
molotov dans ce centre d'accueil
improvisés des bénévoles distribuent de
la nourriture
une solidarité nationale de micco live à
kiev alors même que la capitale est
encerclée par les russes pour ces
bénévoles qui viennent en aide à ces
réfugiés de l'est pas question de
quitter le pays
pour la simple raison que nous sommes
ukrainien nous n'avons pas le choix on
ne peut pas s'en aller alors que notre
peuple est en train de mourir et si
une résistance civile pour leur pays au
risque de leur vie